it's been a tough Journey for these
people
they spend Days on the Road braving
military checkpoints Bandits and Aunt
militias
they finally made it to Port Sudan for a
final trip to reunite with their loved
ones in Qatar and elsewhere
is a Qatar resident who was stranded in
Sudan she and her four children are
among a group of people evacuated by
Qatar
um
the road trip was difficult we traveled
through areas affected by heavy rains
and floods once we arrived here we got
stuck for 23 days before being allowed
to leave this is the 11th humanitarian
flight by Qatar which has established an
air bridge to deliver essential supplies
and evacuate people stranded in the war
ravaged country
there's no indication Sudan's warring
sides are willing to agree on a longer
cease fire and that will make it even
more difficult for those trying to
escape the fighting a growing number of
Sudanese are Crossing into neighboring
countries while Millions more remain
trapped at home they have nowhere else
to go desperate and in need of a
humanitarian help they fear the worst
may be yet to come
heavy clashes broke out between rival
factions after a three-day ceasefire
expired the Army and the Parliamentary
rapid support forces have been battling
each other for more than two months
the conflict has shattered lives
destroyed areas shut down schools
Muhammad NASA came all the way from
North Korea he hopes to live in turkey
and study there
I'm worried about Sudan the future is
uncertain we have no idea what will
happen next
for now the evacuees will have to cope
with a new life far from their country
and hope one day fighting in Sudan comes
to an end peace is restored and people
are able to go back to their homes
Sudan